when we're organizing opportunities that
we're going to pursue with a business we
look at what are the ones that we have
the absolute highest likelihood of
success we need no new skills and no new
effort if we can do that or the least
amount of new effort and no new skills
that would be the first thing we're
going to do and then once we take off
all the ones that take basically no
effort and no extra skills we're like
okay which ones take more effort and
still no skills and then once we do that
then we're like okay now we can start
learning a new skill and of the
different skills that we could learn
which of these is going to give us the
highest leverage as in most output for
the least amount of input and that's
pretty much how we tick down which of
these opportunities we want to pursue
because those have the lowest likelihood
of not happening